all right Frank where are you right now
none of your business come on Fletch
aren't you bored
I got that police report
Ed uh what's the password go f yourself
my father's vein things were stolen
the Picasso was appraised at 20 million
dollars well it hardly seems worth
stealing you're not a detective but it
was an investigative reporter it's an
occupation that's been cheapened by the
digital age like president
Earl Maurice Fletcher they caught me in
the middle of a yawn you imagine that
killed this young woman I think the
victim interrupted an art theft
your fingerprints are on the murder
weapon and someone matching your
description was seen with the victim
come back with me to Police Headquarters
I get it you want my help okay hey guys
this is why we can call in a coffee or a
kill for a macchiato not literally I
looked into your criminal record and
you're a bit of a shady character Mr
Fletcher but I am adorable
if you did kill that girl do the right
thing and give me an exclusive let's
talk about the suspects
somehow she's involved
she's trying to seduce me
for the collection of a preciousness
those are reproductions that's how we
introduce my children
did you lie to me
[Music]
[Music]
no I didn't did you what is this wooden
bird and burn
almost
[Music]
this stupid idiot [ __ ] has something to
do with this you want me on the outside
so I can solve this thing
are you Fletcher yes I am oh I mean no
I'm not I always get that wrong
I don't know what people hate more cops
or reporters
it's cops